this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so supporting each other
through challenging times that's what
we've been doing sorry for the technical
difficulties try to be safe out there
this love people send in pictures of
them wearing masks ever especially
people that travel around sales force
people interacting with others you know
there's places where you don't have to
wear it you know you're outside you got
a lot of room maybe not to wear it but
of course you're gonna get in near
anybody certainly your fellow employees
you want to be careful about that I just
remind you again that our industry
industry leaders professional grounds
management society National Association
of landscape professionals as well as
your local colleagues have a lot of
resources that you can draw on to make
sure you're sort of keeping yourself
safe and following all the guidance that
changes very rapidly some of Matt's
colleagues at Rutgers University
Meredith in particular out of the
diagnostic lab providing some really
good information on the kinds of
sanitation of surfaces that you should
pay attention to you know there was a
lot of confusion I'll just spray bleach
how do I do it what's the solution
what's the best way to handle it and I
thought Meredith did a nice job big
kudos to the plant and pest advisory
service that I know rich our power rich
buckley's involved in all right well
working out there means a lot more
vehicles on the road and if you look at
a local contractor that we work with
down at our Greenwood project Brightview
led a Blee by Enrique Levesque a
longtime golf course colleague running
the crews down there you can see the the
amount of material that's coming out
there to keep the worker safe bigger
cabs a lot more trucks separating
workforces keeping them separate making
the distance these are the kinds of
adaptations we better get used to
because it looks like this is the way
the business is going to get done at
least for the foreseeable future now of
course there's always this option but
I'd pulled this out of the old thing the
self quarantining mower so you could
stay away from your wife
kids which could be agreeable to many
who are locked out with their spouses
over long periods of time all right
let's look at the weather um when we
started about a month ago or more now
we're in our seventh week of this it
looked like the soils were coming on
pretty good in early April we were in
the mid to low 50s and I'm sure Matt and
I were talking about wow crabgrass could
get going soon well by the 29th the end
of the month it had barely budged in the
metropolitan area but recently we're
starting to see that surged over the
last few weeks now overall you look at
where we've been we were about three
weeks behind by the end of April and we
remain in many places three weeks behind
even in New Brunswick where Matt is
still a little bit behind the the
projections now are not good we're gonna
get snow up here on the weekend that we
were laughing it's okay to laugh about
it I guess but but we remain in
single-digit accumulation so there's a
significant part of the northeastern
United States won't see an average
temperature over 50 degrees for the next
five to six days so keep in mind that it
looks like everything is going to remain
in a state of suspended animation and
and of course here you have Georgia
grass lawn with some winter annuals or
cool season grasses coming up in it
we're seeing this a lot throughout the
Northeast very typical in the
metropolitan New York area actually took
this picture when I was a kid in in the
70s I was fascinated by how this lawn
was so brown even as a kid now it's
interesting we're gonna talk about weed
control with dark my colleague Matt
Elmore here in a second but there's this
movement afoot in the turf industry and
beyond to begin to reintroduce clover
into the lawn this is some work that a
PhD candidate out in Utah State
University Paige Boyle is working on
interceding
clover with cool season grasses to
enhance drought tolerance in particular
is the one and you can see some of the
clover plots in this case look
significantly greener in this picture
that she just took very recently
well I welcome at two to the chat here
and just say boy I was like many in the
early just about last week four or five
days ago we saw that little bit of a
snap weather that started the emergence
call and last week man I talked a little
bit about the photons a model that hey
that he developed many years ago and I
don't you know we could debate how
accurate it is for it but what I was
saying last week is is that you see in
this case you've got this really steep
line where over a period of growing
degree days the germination occurs
fairly rapidly and then another study
that was done out in Ontario Canada and
some residential lawns where they showed
emergence to be much flatter now some of
this could be a function of the way they
accumulate degree days but obviously I
know you've been studying this this has
been important because of the variety of
growth stages we could encounter as we
see our pries fail or maybe improving
our pre-emergent applications we got to
assume most people certainly have their
pre-emergence down in the Hudson Valley
and South you did a wonderful job in
your publication Matt on crabgrass and
goose grass outlining the various
options we have for this now obviously
that's where I want to start our
conversation for a minute now and then I
want to get back to some broadleaf
discussion so I'm sort of talked a
little bit about the grass emergence
let's talk grass emergence there's you
know still grass there's crabgrass
there's Bruce grass maybe even Kyle Inga
I think you you said even emerged from
rhizomes early um what's the cold
weather doing to these emergence
patterns it looked like that little bit
of
whether gave us a flush and now it seems
like it's sitting there what do you see
it yeah I think that's correct
it just it depends on the weed a little
bit you know crabgrass some of it has
come up you know if you look at that
finanza model which I think models are a
good guide you never want to rely on
totally but you know that fideo model
would show that there's gonna there's
been a little bit of emergence I think
when we get some really warm
temperatures we'll get get more
crabgrass emergence and even you know
really dense turf areas but yeah the
crabgrass came up the stiltgrass came up
I was out a couple weeks ago
and noticed that the frost was actually
having an effect on some of these weeds
that had come you know he had warm
temperatures and then we had a frost and
most of the crabgrass I think did okay
through that it survived I think some of
this still grass probably it just
depends on the area you know even micro
climates you know in terms of what got
burned back I saw a lot of still grass
that got burned back by the frost a lot
of Kalinga they got burned back by the
frost so how worried are you that early
applications that might have been made
when we were sniffing germination late
March early April now I'm concerned are
you knew about those petering out
quicker or has the longer cooler
temperatures probably left the barrier
in place and you're probably still gonna
get your 12 14 16 weeks yeah it's a good
question I mean I think what we've seen
is that if you apply you know early
basically in say late February early
March mid March whatever you will loose
a little bit of efficacy compared to
maybe if you're applying you know write
it for a city of full bloom and it
really depends on the history of
crabgrass at the site so I'd say you
could lose some efficacy you know you
will you wouldn't lose an entire month
because the temperatures have been cool
like I you know this is a little bit of
a guest estimation I guess but say if
you know you applied for weeks early
with cool temperatures it might might
only be you really only lose two weeks
is it back into that kind of thing but
yeah these these longer seasons are
going to be challenging of these
pre-emergent herbicides
especially if it stays warm for the you
know end of the summer
Jim Brosnan and I were just talking
about this this week in our webinar and
on goose grass and and you know we think
you know regardless of what the weeds
are you know if we get if you're you
know if you're going out early and the
season is extended farther into even
September due to warm temperatures then
you're just putting more pressure on
those breeze and we need to start
thinking about having the multiple
strategies beyond just pre-emergent
herbicides or changing our pre-emergent
herbicide application strategies and I
think thinking about what you've done in
the past and if that's working for you
I'd say you know you can continue on
that course you know trying to think
about how the climate is changing but
I'd say if you have if what you've been
doing and it hasn't been working now
multiple years in a row we need you need
to start thinking about it is in
multiple applications do I need to
really focus on improving that turf
density in the spring and the fall
because that's really what's gonna be
our best defense so yeah I mean I guess
the short answer is the season seasons
are getting longer I think and putting
more pressure on these pre-emergent
service so what are some of these other
strategies let's and you know here's the
thing you've taught me recently and I
wasn't paying attention but you know
we're getting more problems with
different grasses it's not just
crabgrass anymore and it could be goose
grass obviously still grasses is in the
shade but if we just focus on crab and
goose what are some of the alternative
strategies you guys are throwing around
I mean do I want to put another pre that
maybe hangs on too long do what if it's
not been working
obviously we'll assume that getting turf
densities job one but job true then is
altering some kind of chemical strategy
what what are you guys tossing around
yeah I mean so I think looking at some
different you know trying to make a
pre-application at the appropriate
timing before the plants come up and
then maybe trying to work in a post
emergence application later in the
season to try to bridge that gap because
like you say you don't necessarily
I want to be applying a pre and in you
know late July or even mid-july a lot of
times if you're trying to you know
oversee it in the fall or whatever you
don't want to affect the the routing of
the turfgrass and the potentials
proceeding so yeah I mean I haven't what
I've been telling a lot of a lot of
people is just keep a post emergence
herbicide no on the shelf that you have
available to use in the late summer and
the other really tough thing though is
that the post emergence herbicides you
really need to be scouting for the weeds
because if you wait until you have a
goose grass plant the size of a dinner
plate you know you're not gonna be
you're not gonna be in a good spot for
post emergence herbicides so I think you
know it's pre-emergent herbicides like
you know we've done in the past but
keeping an eye on models and plant
phenological indicators to make sure
you're making them the application at
the right time and then it's scouting
the areas that you have the worst
problem with the weed trying to get out
and scout those you know at the right
time if you've got a pre you know you
might want to start scouting you know
like late June early July and and look
get down on the canopy and try to look
for those plants that are maybe breaking
through that at pre-emergence because
that's when we typically see them start
to fail as you know early to mid July
you start to see all of a sudden you
know little crab grass seedlings coming
up to try where their control had been
pretty good prior to that so just try
not to wait too late too long and and
listen if it breaks down I pulled up the
slide here that you did in that
publication if if it breaks down you've
got these options now what I think is
fascinating about this and I wonder if
you couldn't take a minute and talk
about it why doesn't Quinn cleric work
in the 3 to 4 tiller stage if we ever
figured out why drive just doesn't work
when the plants that age it's a good
question I don't know if anybody's ever
figured it out we just know that it
doesn't work right didn't it wasn't the
air and patent it did a lot of that work
yeah I don't know that it's ever been
it's ever been you know
the cause has ever been discovered have
you I haven't read anything on yeah me
neither I thought maybe you know since
you've been fussing around with this
what I see is you don't really have
Queen cleric as an option for Goose
grass well yeah and in fact once it gets
big how confident are you that to
promozone or pile X does the job really
well because you know that's our
Achilles heel you are for seeing being a
problem is a lot of our priests don't
get goose grass you're gonna get it and
then you have these post options can you
talk a little bit about how good the
post options are for goose tricks
yeah well I think you kind of point into
the big problem is that once you get to
five to settlers on goose grass your
only option is to pram is own and it
works fairly well but you're probably
not going to be making just one
application once the plants get that
large so it's gonna be multiple
applications and the other kind of scary
thing is there's only one herbicide
listed there so if we look at a weed
with potential to evolve resistance and
goose grass has shown the ability to do
that then it's kind of concerning so
we've actually been looking at it's not
listed in that publication but we've
been looking at mixtures of two prama
zone and speed zone to try to you know
come up with some alternatives but I
think a lot of its I think you know it's
tough to do on a large scale when you're
running you know a large business but
trying to think about those cultural
practices in the fall because what we
really found when we did a lot of that
goose grass emergence work was that even
a relatively poor turf grass canopy will
reduce the number of seedlings that
emerge by about sixty to seventy percent
so you think about even a poor stand of
turf is really taking quite a bit of
pressure off those pre-emergent
herbicides in terms of the you know the
number of seedlings a good stand of turf
is gonna do a lot more and so I think
that is is important and so you know if
you're trying to come but you're saying
so you're saying are you suggesting
goose grass isn't as competitive in a
turf grass stand because it's maybe not
getting hot enough burs
yeah well yeah she's got a goose grass
question my clock is ticking yeah so I
think you know it's interesting we saw
last year when we had a cool spring the
goose grass didn't seem as competitive
it came up then we had a lot of cool
temperatures and it just never seemed to
get going as bad as it did and in 2018
so I think that I think having that turf
rest there in the beginning a good stand
of turf in the spring to help out
compete those seedlings is really
important I think you know both
crabgrass and goose grass are
competitive enough that if there's
enough seedlings there they're going to
come out through a really dense tainted
turf but if you can take the pressure
off of that herbicide as much as you
came with cultural practices especially
with a weed like goose grass that you
know has this propensity to develop
resistance know we I haven't really put
out the results yet but we surveyed
about 25 golf courses and an athletic
fields in New Jersey last year for
resistance to defy up here huh and we
found that I think it was I think we we
had 23 populations that came up well and
did well in our greenhouse trial and I
think we're still kind of trying to
crunch the numbers a little bit but it
looks like about 17 of those 23 have
some kind of resistance to defy here so
now of course we went into areas where
they've been had a history of Goose
grass problems they had been applying
pre-emergent herbicides it was primarily
golf courses but that was a little bit
startling in terms of wow this weed you
know may may have evolved quite a bit
under some of these selection pressures
so pretty well and I think the same
thing could happen with with pilots if
that toupper Amazon if that gives used
too heavily for Goose grass so that's a
big problem in the mid-atlantic
I don't think there's been some
resistance to kawin chloric reported
with crabgrass a little bit I thought oh
sorry and the knocks of Prop I don't
think that's as widespread though so
it's something to be concerned about
with crabgrass too but yeah those weeds
going back to that slides when they get
big yeah you know we just there's
nothing to control them so I think
site knowing the site history is really
important I don't wanna I know that the
clock is ticking I don't want it to fall
off the couch I want to get your
thoughts on broadleaf weed control maybe
before we take some questions this is
the model we use that was developed at
Purdue many years ago we still post it
on our forecast website and as you can
see it's indicating these early spring
applications of the esta formulation at
two four D are you know still May
they're starting to finally be
favourable in your neck of the woods but
for much of the Northeast not very good
now in addition to that Matt everybody
notices these problems in the spring
ground ivy and and violet and so with
that the cooler temperatures
there you go how's she doing bring her
over so yeah so those weeds are sitting
there is an herbicide application going
to control them how is this crazy
weather going to affect our early spring
broadleaf applications because I think
puffballs are already through dandelions
and I don't think they maybe we're ready
to be controlled what do you think about
we know it's not the best time to
control weeds what do you think about
spring weed control broadly yeah yeah I
mean I think it's possible they're
waiting until things get a little warmer
especially as you move north and on that
map you showed might be a good idea and
I think if you're not if you don't make
those applications for Daniel and
control before you know they start to
flower then you might want to wait till
after they are done flowering there was
some good work that Dane round and Bush
Ohio State did that showed you know if
you're having problems with broadleaf
weed control and dandelion control you
know if you apply in full bloom
those herbicides aren't going to work as
well as if you get it either before or
after the bloom so you know we're not
talking about waiting till July but
maybe waiting till late May I mean here
we're probably a couple weeks away from
being through flowering but I would say
if you get you know noir into western
New York and North you're probably not
things are probably a little different
so yeah you want to I mean waiting til
the temperatures are warm is good
so yeah come on over I'll pal fast if
you want to come over here okay come on
over here we go oh but yeah I think
waiting till temperatures are warm is
important applying when we're getting
nighttime temperatures in the 30s and
that's for controlling sort of simple to
control weeds like dandelion but then
you get into ground ivy and violence and
my sense is yeah there she goes that my
sense is if there's not try clip air in
there that it's not gonna work as well
yeah I think that's the big thing with
those weeds is product selection like
you say it's got to be trike look your
flock secure works pretty well too so
those sort of maybe products that are a
little bit more maybe not as economical
is just the 240m cpa die cam is a that's
I think that's the big thing it's more
product selection than timing I think
it's it's both I mean what you've seen
the research shows that fall
applications work well but of course
we're sitting here in spring so we don't
need to talk about that we want a
solution now all right so you know I
think we're getting close to the window
that would be ideal for those weeds
they're starting to metabolize you know
starting to grow a little bit more
actually all right Carl I think we're
ready for questions how we doing good so
there was one question about someone
texting in the chat line about
introducing things like heel all or
prunella to bloom in the lawn during the
summer so I did send along a link to the
Minnesota B lon I know there's there's a
little bit more of a push now to have
lawns that have flower and weeds for the
pollinators but also kind of for
aesthetic purposes so I passed that link
along and the chat box and also Joe and
lemon and the New York State IPM office
has a trial this year that she's doing
with these pollinator lawns so people
look out for that and then just another
question from Lori and immature and man
question and answer box she's asking
about consumer product selections for
goose gas I don't know if there's
consumer availability for those products
you guys yeah let's take the goose grass
question first and then I'll I talk
about flowers and lawns go ahead Matt
what about goose grass question
now consumer goose crap yeah there are
some products that contain phenoxy prep
in the big-box stores I can't remember
the D I think it's I can't remember the
exact brand name but there are some
consumer products that contain phenoxy
prep I should remember because we have a
publication on crabgrass and goose grass
control for for homeowners so if you
google you know Rutgers extension or
have a document for professionals then
we also have a document specifically
written for you know a homeowner so
there's kind of lists products that are
available in the big-box stores as
opposed to those that are gonna be a lot
of your local distributors all right let
me check that out and I tell you Carl as
you know I brought up the clover point
earlier and you bring up the heel all
and prunella and pollinator lawns as
soon as you start to introduce plants
into a lawn that's not a grass now you
talk about limited chemical options if
you want to go and blanket the place
that essentially limits almost all your
options Matt right when you once you
start having flowering lawns and you
know it changes the definition of sort
of what a weed is to begin with and then
really complicate your sort of any
control you might want to do yeah for
sure
I mean I'd I think there's probably the
probably would be nice to see more
research and kind of how you implement
one of those lawns so that it you know
you keep some grass in there and yeah
and because you want to have that grass
to maintain your ground cover in your
dad ass home yeah this is so great no
extra charge for the family
entertainment here today Matt this is so
great Jesus all what's her name
I'll uh I'll uh this is very strange
did you don't you can't spray anything
for broadleaf weed control so if they
start to overwhelm the lawn I don't know
if you'd want to you think about seeding
more in the fall to try to again keep
some kind of turf there I guess Paige is
doing a lot of that work and Utah yeah
and you know one of the things is that
as you
I to establish any of these diverse
situation diverse lawns where you're
introducing plants from seed a lot of
these natives and plants that we might
want differently like a Florida lawn or
Tom Cook's eco lon
if you're gonna try seeding these things
in they're gonna take a while to
actually establish themselves and that's
right we could use some research in and
around the area of you know a system of
getting these lawns established and then
you know it looks very different I'm
actually thinking Carl maybe it's time
to get Paige up early in the morning in
Utah and have her here to talk about
some of that clover work because even
clover Matt doesn't that complicate not
as much but it complicates weed control
you can still do we control in clover
cuz 240 doesn't get clover as far as I
know yeah yeah you're kind of limited to
two four D options it'll suppress it but
you're right it won't kill it so yeah I
mean there's pastures that have are
managed with clover random so it can be
done it just kinda limits your options
and obviously you're gonna have to be a
little bit more accepting of different
different species maybe moving it along
occasionally and and that kind of thing
yeah I think it can definitely be done
it's just it's just yeah it gives things
a little bit more complicated or
different than what we're used to doing
yeah so let's wrap up here I am thinking
about it is most people's pries if they
went down are still probably going to
hold up because it's been fairly long if
you're had success with your pre program
stick with it if you're questioning it
start thinking about post strategies and
how you'd implement scouting and try to
rotate your products to get your grasses
under control and then broadly thing is
a combination of both product selection
and and timing and that's why of course
now they sell you know q5 or q8 whatever
it is Matt that's got every active
ingredient known to man in a single
compound in a single product so that's
still gonna be timing base for for good
efficacy and no one wants to hear it but
the best time to do this is in the fall
and
we're catching up now so yeah dad on the
pries is that we you know we just did
some work that I think up it's in crop
forage and turf but when we look to
those early applications we looked at
early pre applications in late February
you know thinking there might be some
end users that want to get out early
start going because they got a lot of
accounts to get to and we found that
those late February applications were
not as effective as those made at
forsythia full bloom but that if you
made a reapplication not six to eight
weeks after your your late february
application but six to weeks six to
eight weeks after Presidium loom those
work just as well as applications made
at for city of bloom a single
application so to summarize that you
know if you're making an early
application make the next and you want
to use a split program make the next
application not six to eight weeks after
the initial application the six to eight
weeks after forsythia full bloom because
of that you know they're not breaking
down very quickly right now so you don't
have to make again that rehab is six to
eight weeks after the application but
rather the persevere full-blown yeah i
wasn't aware of that paper that's gotta
be one will make sure we set up a link
to if we can get at it
matt thanks so much for joining us and
thanks to your daughter for the cameo
appearance around there yeah we're stuck
like this until things get a little more
back to normal so mom yeah well III here
day here they kicked buckley out of his
bedroom and they sent him back to
alright so Carl's our survey yep I just
put the link again to our survey so you
know thanks to everyone who's already
filled it out I know we're getting you
know forty five responses I think
already so far so but if you haven't you
know go check that out real quick and I
think that's it for today right on the
money Frank half an hour exactly Matt
again thanks for joining us
big shout out to your wife who's in the
health care industry and on the front
lines there so thanks for thanks for
joining us now
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu